what's going on everybody welcome to
part 27 of our matplotlib tutorial
series in this part we're going to
continue talking about base map and here
we're going to talk about some of the
options available to us with base map
and their various functions and methods
that we can run with it
so where we started off in kind of where
we left off was with just a simple
representation using the Miller
projection of our base map graph now or
chart or map whatever you want to call
it now the next thing that I want us to
go ahead and do is talk about some of
the more the options that we have so
instead of it we're gonna stop I'm gonna
stop filling the continents for now but
just know you can fill the continents
and you can also change the color if you
if you want now in the projection we can
also add some more some more coordinates
and the way that these coordinates are
working is let me close out of this old
version of paint
don't save and we'll open up paint and
the way that it coordinates work is
you've got you know your entire map
might be like this and then you know
you've got stuff on the map let's say
I'm not gonna attempt to draw the world
but let's just assume okay so this is
our map and then generally you pick two
points you pick the lower left corner
point and then you pick the lower or the
upper right corner point okay so we're
gonna pick that point and for those of
you who are not too familiar with maps
coordinates are in latitude and
longitude longitude goes left to right
okay and that's the long kind of left to
right longitude and then latitude is the
up and down okay so this is your
latitude now with latitude and longitude
the interesting thing that comes up with
plotting in a graph like situation
generally coordinates are reported as
lat/long so latitude longitude but what
is latitude mostly in relation to well
latitude is most like the y-axis and
longitude is most like the x-axis so at
some point with matplotlib we have to
flip these around
to be to conform to the XY requirement
of graphs but you have to understand
that they're reported as YX but anyway
more on that later but back to the
original when we define a coordinate box
with base map we defined the lower left
and then the upper right the lower left
that's the XY coordinate for the lower
left point and then the XY for the
coordinate up here and then what ends up
happening is with these two points we
can draw a box that will be our graph so
we can draw a box like this right and
that's the box that is made up by these
coordinates not quite perfect but that's
the idea so what we can do is we can
minimize this and then we can say so we
want to have the Miller projection and
then we use a parameter called LLC RN R
la T that's lower left corner latitude
and let's say the lower left corner
latitude will be negative 40 and then
lower left corner longitude will also be
negative 40 we're gonna we're gonna have
this kind of focus in on Africa for us
and then oh you are CR n R lat so that's
upper right corner lat
will be 50 and then the upper right
corner long will be 75 okay so our
bottom or a lower left point will be
negative 40 negative 40 and then our
upper right coordinate will be 50 75 so
that brings up another point is with
latitude and longitude generally what we
have is you've got you know your your
axes that'll look like this and
generally you've got north-south this
would be your West and this is your East
but in matplotlib you've got basically a
plus minus minus plus so all Eastern
coordinates are really pluses all
Western coordinates are negatives
northern coordinates are pluses southern
coordinates or negatives okay so this
coordinate
here negative 40 negative 40 what is
that
well that latitude is negative 40 that
would be south and then you've got
negative 40 or I'm sorry that would be
40 South not negative 40 South that
would make no sense so 40 South
forty West then you've got this 50 would
be 50 north and then 75 East basically
so let's do so let's go ahead and run
this real quick and see what comes up so
what we get is Africa with a little bit
of outlying Europe and slightly Asia
over here but mostly what we're looking
at is Africa now there's one more thing
that we can show with graphs and that
would be the resolution you can do comma
resolution and for now we'll do C so the
default is C which stands for crude and
so when we zoom in let's like zoom in
here okay you've got like it's very
jaggedy right there's not very much
resolution here on the full term scale
or even especially like a full map it
looks okay like there's a little bit of
rounded edges but not really but
so that was crude then you have low so
that would be L for low and that takes a
little longer and you can see actually
we get we got a few more rivers we got
some islands over here and then again we
can zoom into that same Lake and we can
see yeah there's definitely a lot more
granularity going on there you've got
crude low I think H would be high and I
believe F is for full we'll have to find
out for sure there but I believe F will
be our full this one takes a little
longer and each step of the way is an 80
percent change so basically yeah you're
like almost improving eighty percent I
suppose and so anyway here with what we
do hi I think we got a lot more detail
here and again let's just keep zooming
into that same Lake right now you got
even more detail here I mean even
showing the full lake we really don't
see
that much jaggedy edges anymore and
stuff but then we also again we got way
more islands over here that we can
actually zoom into and they're like you
know zoom way into these islands so
there's that and then there's finally f
is full let me just try to run that it's
gonna take a while to load that one but
that is another option that you have so
while we're waiting on that I'm gonna go
ahead and change this back to will just
will do l for low that's pretty quick
loading and some of the other things
that we're able to do we can also do
something like with like the United
States we can do something like this we
can say let's do this draw coastlines
well first of all what we can do is we
can do MDOT draw let's do draw countries
first countries so we can draw countries
that map come up you thank you this is
gonna take a while so what this will do
is allow us to draw countries but not
only do it can we draw countries but we
can throw other parameters in here that
are like our original matplotlib
parameters so an example of this would
be like line width and we could say line
width equals two okay and I'm gonna run
this in last night it's still not up yet
I was really hoping to get a full
resolution to show you guys but I don't
want sit here I don't know how long it's
gonna take me to to render the the full
one still not there I guess we can just
skip it but you can feel free to wait on
it yourself if you'd like but yeah it's
just not gonna pop up let's just give
that for now so now we've got the
country definitions here so you can see
that we've got like the split of
everything and actually what I'll go
ahead and do is I'll have us return back
let's do negative 90 negative 180 and
then here this will be 90 180 so this
would be the full world again for us
there you go
so you can see the country definitions
they have a thicker line width right
because we chose them to be line width
of two but now you've got definition
between the United States Canada and
then
down here like Brazil and Chile and all
that I'll split up and then you've got
here in Africa and Europe we can see all
the divisions now we can close this and
that was so draw countries we can have
that but another thing we can have is m
dot draw states and we can color these
and we can have States B let's do now we
need something that we can see really
well let's do B for blue so save that
and run so let's take a little bit
longer but yeah so now we've got the
States drawn and you should see now that
we've separated Australia as well but
mainly we were interested in like the
United States so we get the States there
so those are all separated as you know
each of their own another thing that we
can do we can even take it in another
sector basically and we can do em dot
draw counties so now we have the
counties of every state and trying to
think of a color for these we'll call
these dark red see if we can get away
with that I've never tried these fancy
colors these will take a long time to
there's a lot of like little lines for
counties but that worked out cool so we
can zoom in a little bit here and then
we can zoom in to see the counties so
now you can see that we've all the
counties for the United States all taken
care of lol at the amount of counties
for Alaska not many people care anyway
okay so we've got that there's a couple
other things that we can do let's close
out of here let's stop drawing I wanted
to just show the counties but that takes
up a lot of time so I'm going to comment
that out and then another thing that we
can do is we can add topography so we
can say something like this MMD topo and
we can add topography to our graph so
this will take a little bit to load but
it should come up pretty quick and
another thing to note with topography
and the next one I'm about to show you
guys the resolution you draw should
should affect these so the higher the
resolution the the longer it will take
to draw these now we're doing a low I
think but yeah so here's your topography
so now we've got topography
on this graph if that's something you're
interested in but we still have the
divisions as well so all the country
divisions and all the state diff
divisions and all that alongside the
topography we have so there you go got
those but you can see like as you zoom
in they're getting kind of like grainy
and fuzzy so if you want to you can
increase the resolution and that will
improve now that was M the topography
another one you can do is m dot Blue
Marble and this would be the last one I
show you before we finish up this
specific tutorial and while we wait the
next tutorial we're going to cover
actually plotting a coordinate so
probably the main reason you're gonna
graph something with a map is not just
to look at a map alright you may care
about making the divisions between
States and countries and all that but
generally you're gonna want to plot
something on the map so anyway here's
Blue Marble it's kind of like the
topography only it's a Blue Marble so
you also get you know the oceans in here
and also the green versus you know
desert and all that and to get a little
more information here with the Blue
Marble but anyway you choose to do
whatever the heck you want to do so
anyway I just wanted to show you guys
all those kind of options with the
graphs that the Blue Marble is the most
kind of realistic looking graph and
again you can you can take blue marble
and you can actually do like a really
high resolution but if you're going to
do a high resolution you should probably
zoom in first and then apply the high
resolution rather than have the full
graph apply the resolution and then
yourself on the graph zoom in and what I
mean by zoom in is is modify these
coordinates here to be whatever location
you're truly interested in rather than
rendering everything for all the
locations so anyways that's it for this
tutorial
stay tuned the next tutorial for
actually plotting coordinates and stuff
like that on the map if you have any
questions or comments regarding this
tutorial or whatever up to this tutorial
please feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
things for all the supportive
subscriptions and until next time